i know all of you know that palm springs
is kind of the official start of the
award season when it comes up we know
that we're getting into the thick of
things and so here a lot of you are
again being recognized with the ensemble
performance for this film um will i'm
going to start with you what does it
mean for you to be here with this group
being recognized for this film
yeah you know it is
uh
such a beautiful
honor this group
right here every day
on set
through
through covid you know through
uh and you know we were shooting in the
in the middle of the the
initial onset of covid so we were among
the you know the first groups that had
to learn how to figure how you're going
to make a movie while you were doing it
and the way that this this group fell
into
the the the roles of
family and and friends you know we we
we felt like war buddies
the chances of achieving the kind of
success that you're talking about it's
just very very unlikely okay you're
making a mistake but i'm gonna let you
make it
you know
coming coming out of here coming out of
this thing
but the the value and the importance
of the story to have
venus and and serena and the williams
family on
set with us and if it felt like we were
doing something that that had
true
value it was it was things that we all
agreed with
just as human beings that we wanted to
say and we wanted to put into the world
um
and it was it was just you know one of
the the the most beautiful experiences
of my career being able to watch sanaya
and and demi
you know uh suffer
and triumph was you know just it brings
tears to my eyes when i when i even
think about it i want to go to sanya and
jimmy though real quick because will you
mention something about like
being family and friends and i have to
tell you i mean as much as i love seeing
this ensemble i could not take my eyes
off of you two girls together on screen
doing the work that you did so
congratulations to youtube for sure but
tell me about that chemistry how was
that born between the two of you was it
immediate i'm gonna start with you and i
and then jimmy i want you to chime in
oh my goodness that's my little sister
guys um
man i mean i mean honestly as soon as i
learned that i booked the roll mr ray
i was like hi sanaya um this is demi's
number
you're her big sister now so you need to
start talking
and i was like all right here we go and
she kind of instantly became my serena
and it was it was
it was kind of awkward at first but then
after a while it just kind of
naturally happened like we just
we're like twin flames it was beautiful
like to watch and i love her so very
much and i think we both
i don't know we grew as actresses and
i'm just so very proud of her it makes
me so emotional how venus feels about
stream is how i feel about
the most dangerous creature on this
whole earth
it's a woman who know how to think yes
daddy it's definitely a little awkward
at first so we always joke about it now
because i remember the first day we met
we were just like so quiet we're like
staring at each other we didn't say
anything
you know but you know we're really
really close now
i'll literally call her every day just
like a new a new issue every day so now
what am i gonna wear what am i gonna eat
i don't know what to do with my
boyfriend she picks up the phone even
even though she knows she's gonna have
to be dealing with some of my nonsense
and she sits there for however long it
takes for me to find my own pick what i
want to eat and she she is like she's
like the bigger sister that i've never
really had i am i'm the oldest one so
she is really my little sister and i'm
so freaky
i love hearing that you don't hear that
often you know coming out of movie sets
a lot of times to know that a genuine
sisterhood a genuine friendship has been
built so i love to hear that um tony and
john i want to come to you guys and ask
you both because this is an ensemble um
i'm wondering is there a memory with
this entire group together really offset
maybe even while making this film that
stood out as a favorite memory for you
guys tony i'm gonna start with you and
then john um you can pick up
yeah sure i mean the ensemble thing is
such a perfect
uh it feels like this company is it's
just such a great description of this
what the atmosphere of this film was
um because to answer your question
um the first time when we were in
rehearsal that i was with
um
the family
i was
really overwhelmed by the um the
relationship that they had all forged
off camera or completely you know
naturally and organically they were a
family all this gaggle of girls
all wrapped up in each other dancing and
talking and will and
being literally mom you know
you know come on we gotta get to work
now come on and yeah
making fun of them and so and then you
know when i stepped in they just
welcomed me right into the family and in
honesty in the way that the williams has
did with paul cohen my characters watch
him hit a few balls all right so tell me
your names again i'm venus i'm serena
so what'd you think
it really uh immediately let me know you
know what the
what the the really unique nature of
this project was going to be and it was
all about family you know it was one of
those things that you feel when you
are welcomed into a family it's a very
special um
it's a very special experience in in any
situation and on a on a film set you
know it's it's um it's rarer you know
because everyone's there doing a job but
uh it's always it's best when that
happens and and so you know having the
palm springs recognize that in this
movie is really really amazing i love
that john i remember being in scenes and
just being able to look at anjanu just
us being able to share look there's no
written dialogue really between us and
my whole chemistry change everything in
me chain and there's just anywhere you
look you can look at somebody who is
right there with you and will affect you
and everything matters and everything's
vital and
that's when you play together as a full
instrument and it is my absolute
favorite acting to be a part of it's why
i do this i just had what oprah calls a
light bulb moment because john you said
and that's what it was ingenue it's
those looks
it's those
it's the unwritten word it's those quiet
moments like we're going to talk about
you like you're not in the room for a
second just so you will can you just
speak to
um
you know there was that moment when it's
the scene with the two of you and she's
given you your business and it was that
quiet moment at the end that just
melted me it melted me
can you just talk about like
being with her as an actress and what
ingenue brought to this movie and then
to oris
so we we've talked about in his heart
it's hard to describe
to like to if you've if you've never
been in a scene right so
so sometimes you you feel like you toss
something
at an actor and it just misses and falls
on on the floor
right and then every once in a while it
comes back at you in a way that you
never even imagined it's almost like a
dance it's like a like a sparring match
and anja knew
like like all
great actors knows how to push buttons
inside of you that you're
not expecting or not used to having
pushed
right and
you know you you see it in sports a lot
where you you know where athletes will
will elevate to the level of the the
people that they're they're playing with
you know and that's definitely
what happened for me
going toe-to-toe in those scenes with
with with anjanu it's a magical
chemistry thing that you can't buy
you you know you can't uh demand it's
just something that is is magic and and
you know uh anjanu is a is a magic maker
yes
absolutely okay
ma'am no ma'am you're gonna have to sit
here and take this today
[Laughter]
and now i do want to ask you aunjanu
will king richard this film go down as
one of the most impactful roles that
you've done and is there a specific
scene or is there a reason why
that would be
the case for you to do the best work
that i can do i have to feel
this there's this phrase that we use in
church all the time feeling propped up
on every leaning side
and um that's what that's what my
experience was working on working on
this film and i cannot say enough that
about
what it was like for me
to be a part of history as i see it
because i know
that in you know a few years
you know jimmy singleton and sanaya
sydney
are going to be you know
the our our our touchstones of like of
of what um
you know acting is for for for for for
women
in uh in american cinema and i i can say
i was i was there you know i was
there when you know when when when that
happened and
you know i was with
tony gold gold you know goldwyn who i
have so much respect for and i've had so
much respect for for so many years and
have watched john bernthal
in in films and not knowing who he was
personally of course but just seeing him
in things and just thinking like if
there was something so so raw and
just so
i don't know like of the constellations
like that energy that thing that you
know like physical stars have and
and then i
you know work with will smith who is a
superstar but everybody who you know
wants to be a superstar should come and
watch how this superstar works because
he works in a way
that
is not just about
not just about
his kindness
is what is most important to him when he
walks on set every day and so when you
have a scene partner like that when you
have a producer like that
um
it just makes you better
it just makes you better it makes you
feel like you can take risks it makes
you feel like you don't have to perform
it just makes you feel like you can just
show up and have an experience with
someone someone on camera and the fact
that we were doing that all in the in
the project of honoring the this
williams family
you know i would look around every day
you know and just think you know to
myself
you know i did something right at some
point in my life
well i do want to ask you this question
too i want to throw this to you because
the movie is called king richard you've
had some very impactful roles in your
career but this one
how does it go down in the pantheon of
what you've done is it was one of the
most impactful roles that you've done
yeah
this one is special it's still
it's still going and
you know it's funny
because you make the movie and then
there's a period when you're away from
it while it's being edited and put
together and all of that so you get
distance from it
so by the time the film is coming out
you've potentially
made one or two
other things in your mind you've moved
on in your mind so when the audience
sees it
it's almost like you're getting to see
it again
or you're seeing it for the first time
along with the audience
and
i was i was
completely
and
utterly blown away at what rey was able
to do so
delicately
with
this film you know it it it it walks a
razor's edge
of
really powerful drama it's hilarious
when it's funny yeah right it's
hilarious you know you laugh like a
comedy you know and then you cry it's
like you know you always you always hear
that cliche oh i laughed i cried it was
like it's one of those films that really
it covers a broad uh spectrum
of emotion and ideas that's that's truly
rare and um i i had secretly
in my mind
felt that i would never make anything
better than the pursuit of happiness
[Music]